it's becoming more and more difficult to
be an independent human being especially
with a family so one of uh one segment I
recorded on is AOC wants to raise income
uh the income tax on New York residents
who are in the top 5% of income earners
the top 5% is not the same as the top 1%
it's a it's it's a huge leap and there
was an organization that said basically
what you're saying is anybody who makes
$250,000 a year or more in New York City
now $250,000 a year is a lot of money
but in New York City the you're talking
about a man and woman who who are both
working full-time hard enough to have a
family and they're each making like 127
and they're living in Jersey and they're
or or right and living in Jersey a
one-bedroom apartment is four grand in
New York city so you're talking about a
third to to uh uh you know about a third
or a little bit more than a third of
your income every month in just rent
don't forget food now what if you want
to have kids as as they increase taxes
and increase the pressure and make it
harder to buy now you're talking do you
want to own you want that's going to be
impossible